coming up next here on c-span we'll
travel to chicago illinois for an
installment in our series america and
the courts
we'll talk with rob warden the author of
greylord justice chicago style
his book focuses on a judicial scandal
in chicago
[Music]
rob warden you just just co-authored a
book called greylord what's it about
it's about judicial corruption in the
city of chicago on a
federal investigation a sting operation
that exposed
the situation
how did uh the the roots of this
corruption in the city what was the
climate that allowed corruption to begin
in the court system here chicago has
always been
a one-party town or at least since the
20s
and the democratic organization has
controlled absolutely every facet of the
life on all three
branches of the government the executive
the legislative and the judicial
to become a judge in cook county you had
to be slated by the regular democratic
organization
you got slated
by doing political work
and
therein were the seeds for corruption
i think that it wasn't a very big step
from
taking a call from a
alderman or a
committeeman to actually taking money
to fix cases
and of course this investigation
didn't get at that underlying corruption
the political corruption the political
fix that's possible in the courts of
cook county but only at the financial
corruption
what's the time frame the book was
written in
with the time period that this story
covered the
investigation
the federal investigation of the cook
county circuit court system began in
1979
and this investigation i believe is
still continuing today
what was it that uh attracted if it had
been going on for such a long time as
you described and it was really sort of
fundamental to the the political
structure in the city what what was it
that finally got people interested in
investigating finding out what was going
on perhaps putting it into it well as
you say for years and years there had
been it had been going on and people had
been aware of it in the 70s when jim
thompson presently the governor of
illinois was the u.s attorney here he
had begun an investigation of the
legislative branch and convicted a
number of chicago aldermen under with
expansive use of the federal mail fraud
statute i think that they just finally
got around to looking at the judiciary
now there had been a very highly
publicized case in cook county in the
late 70s and
involved a mafia hit man
who
there were two eyewitnesses and that's
very rare in a case like this who had
actually seen
a murder take place
this hitman was acquitted
and the state's attorney at the time
bernard carey was extremely upset he'd
gone to the u.s attorney's office then
at about the same time a couple of
prosecutors from the county system
had moved over or one prosecutor had
moved over from the state's attorney's
office into the u.s attorney's office
and was very concerned about judicial
corruption and
there were the seeds for the greylord
investigation
now this investigation involved
fbi agents masquerading as
defendants
as
defense attorneys prosecutors and in one
case a judge
it was a massive massive sting operation
and that operation really didn't take
them very far it only got three or four
judges but
about the same time
a chicago lawyer reporter my co-author
jim tui
had done a major story on a phenomenon
known as hustling
in illinois
if you're arrested and charged with a
crime a minor crime
a bond is set you can post 10 percent of
that bond with the court and you're free
now in many states there are bail bond
systems where you give a bondsman ten
percent if the bond is twenty five
hundred dollars you pay 250 to the
bondsman
well in the early sixties uh illinois
had such a system and it was corrupt
and consequently the legislature
abolished it and put the various
counties into the bail bond system so
when you post bond you get a
bond slip
a few years after establishing this
system the legislature and all of its
wisdom
made those bond slips negotiable
instruments or at least to the extent
that a defendant could endorse it
payable directly to an attorney
so that was the birth of the hustler
people would walk into court maybe
they'd been charged with shoplifting or
maybe a traffic offense or whatever and
they'd have a bond slipped in their hand
and what jim tooie observed in 1980 when
he went out and looked at these branch
courts were the judges and court
personnel
steering these defendants to particular
lawyers
now at the time of course we couldn't
prove why they were steering them but we
knew that it wasn't because the judges
had great confidence in the legal
ability of these lawyers
after we ran this story the federal
government picked that up they checked
the bond slip refunds because there were
records in the and they were able to
show that
these attorneys weren't paying federal
income taxes on all the money that they
were receiving
and they were ultimately able to
persuade those attorneys to testify
against judges they were paying off
and that became the major
uh the centerpiece of operation greylord
where's name come from
uh the uh there are different stories
about where the the name came from
uh we were told initially in fact the
u.s attorney
the recent u.s attorney dan webb told me
that
grey lord was a sarcastic reference to
the english lord
chancellors and
that's the english spelling of gray as
you will see
someone said more recently that actually
there was a racehorse named greylord and
that they just pulled a name out of the
out of the air
i don't really know there are different
perceptions
you made some reference in the early
chapters about the fbi being predisposed
towards sting operations at the time we
talk about that yes
sting operations are obviously
they draw a great amount of publicity
they get
heavy coverage on television in the
newspapers and i think the fbi
grew enamored of those in the
in the 70s j edgar hoover at one point
supposedly had prohibited them or
had very greatly limited them
believing that they were not really an
effective use of law enforcement
but this
took off
right after ab scam which of course was
you know the fbi just got all of this
wonderful publicity and it seems that
almost every sting operation they
conducted had to be just a little bit
bigger and a little bit better than the
one previously and this was going to be
the granddaddy of the mall operation
greylord
unfortunately the sting portions of it
didn't really uh work all that well i
think only three judges were actually
convicted as a result of the sting
and the fbi agents
this involved setting up phony cases to
run them through the system
so for instance the fbi would stage a
strong armed robbery in which the victim
would be an fbi agent and the robber
would be an fbi agent they staged one
right down on michigan avenue on the
magnificent mile right in front of
marshall fielding company one day
and
the they waited until there was a police
officer nearby and
the robber starts running and the victim
chases him and ultimately tackles him
and the police arrested him
well suddenly people were arriving on
the scene and they were volunteering to
testify saying i saw the whole thing
well the police knew that this isn't the
way a real one goes down
furthermore when they got the guy over
to the
police station to book him they searched
him and pulled out his wallet and lo and
behold he was carrying his fbi
identification card
in another case
the
fbi had telephoned an anonymous tip to
the police on the northwest side
that a man was sitting in a restaurant
with a satchel full of cocaine
the police walked in here was the man
just as the anonymous caller had
described they walked up to him and said
what's in the bag
cocaine
just like that well police got wise that
things don't really happen quite like
that
and so the police then had to be taken
in on the
investigation they had to be assured
that they weren't the targets of
whatever the fbi was doing and they were
and so they established a few more that
they
really did get cases into the system
except it's extremely costly
very hard to do in the first place we
had more than 300 judges in the cook
county circuit court at that time and
they sat in various divisions but the
assignments
the case assignments were random
so if you suspected that
a judge was crooked
even if you staged a case you had no way
of assuring that it would get assigned
to the judge where you wanted to attempt
to make the payoff
the
there are other problems i mean for
instance they had an fbi agent uh
ram a car into a light post and he
poured liquor all over himself and and
had just enough so there would be some
on his breath
the police came it was close to the end
of a shift and they didn't want to go
through the paperwork so they just threw
the guy's keys down the gutter and
poured the booze out and sent him home
so they'd go through all of these
elaborate things and then sometimes it
would all come to naught because it
simply wouldn't work
is that sort of a side story to your
book or do you hope also to show that
these kind of operations by the fbi
aren't the best way to go about it my
personal view is that it really isn't an
efficient way
to
investigate corruption that's not the
main point you're talking about oh no no
i mean uh there was certainly uh
was and i believe continues today to be
very
serious
corruption in the circuit court of of
cook county
and this investigation has certainly
gone a long way
toward making the people who are engaged
in that very uncomfortable if not
rooting it out entirely
your book seems to have a number of
villains
and when i read one review and it said
it reads like a novel one of the things
that strikes you is really how blatant
some of
the the actions were how
some of the quotes are almost outrageous
almost as if they were written by a
hollywood scriptwriter as opposed to
well yes now you understand that of
course these things came out in the
trials and
these weren't things that you or i could
go into a courtroom and observe if you
were looking like
i mean wayne olsen one of the judges who
was convicted saying i like people that
take dough because you know where they
stand
or
judge raymond sodini when he saw court
personnel in the back of his courtroom
who appeared to be bickering over
splitting up payoffs that they'd
received from an attorney he told his
bailiff go tell us guys if they're
talking about money to go in the back
room and do it not to talk about it you
know out here in the open well all of
those kinds of things came
out actual testimony
in trials but they weren't something
that we could have observed as
journalists or any other
person who just comes into the court
could see
now you could see a lot of things that
were going on but jim toohey and i had
been covering the courts in cook county
off and on for
more than 20 years
and if you had
asked me to come testify before a grand
jury i wouldn't have a single incident
that i could ever have related
which is why
it takes a massive federal investigation
of this sort
to root it out who are the victims in
stores like this well of course we the
citizens
are the ultimate victims if the
if the justice system
is corrupted we're victims in a number
of ways obviously
if
the drunk driver isn't fined or
something we're financially hurt but
that's a minor part of it
i think that it you know it breeds
disrespect for the law it
in it creates more
lawlessness
than we would otherwise have
and the cook county circuit court
had the reputation
of being corrupt and has the reputation
today
of being corrupt and i think that's the
real
damage that's done
by these
appearances that justice is not done
or that a case can be fixed some judges
can be wired
and another aspect of this corruption
just because of the reputation of the
system
the average person who was charged with
a misdemeanor believed that the system
was corrupt
so if a lawyer said to him well my fee
will be 500
and then comes back
right before the trial or
usually a bench trial and says
well we're going to have to pay off the
judge it'll be another 250.
it was a way that it just enabled
lawyers to extort money
in that way that was called rain making
by the people who engaged in it
that is telling the client that the
lawyer was going to pay a bribe but
actually of course just pocketing the
money
and that was possible simply because of
the reputation
of the system
interestingly
lawyers could tell i mean of course
because of
the
the practice that
this is the evidence maybe a witness is
not going to show up or the evidence is
very weak
the defendant's going to be acquitted
for sure
the lawyer would know and so you could
do this with a great deal of certainty
but
in a case where the lawyer was surprised
if the judge heard the evidence and said
no i find the defendant guilty the
lawyer would then go back and say
gee who have you upset in the
prosecutor's office there was tremendous
heat in this case and the judge just
couldn't do it here's your money back
in most cases were we talking about
large sums of money
well in some cases we were talking about
oh 500 a thousand dollars but in
most cases in some cases we were talking
about extremely small amounts of money
i think one of the things that
amazed
observers in chicago was not that the
corruption was so rife
but that justice was being sold for so
little
some in some cases as little as ten
dollars a case
early on in your book you tell the story
um struck me of one particular judge who
occasionally didn't want to come to
court oh yes we tell that one well
that's judge sadini who ran a
he presided over a gambling court at a
central police headquarters and early in
the morning he had to handle what's
called the bum call
this is the call of all the people who
were swept off the streets basically for
safe keeping
on any given night in chicago they're
all brought in well
judge sadini who drank a lot
would sometimes
have a hangover in the morning and he'd
call in and tell his bailiff to tell the
police sergeant
assigned to his courtroom to put on the
robes and do the bum call so the police
sergeant would
literally put on the judge's robes sit
there and go through this call and these
defendants were all just dismissed
they were
charged with
an offense known as disorderly conduct
which is
really not much of an offense they're
more disheveled and
and pathetic then disorderly
and they're all released
but one of the stories that we told here
one day
a
drunk was being particularly boisterous
in the back and they
saved his case until last and
brought him in and sentenced him to
death it was a rather
unsettling way for him to begin the day
i would suspect
talked about the victims and certainly
the many villains as it were in the
story
are there any heroes are there any good
guys in this book
well i would say
the best guy
was a chicago lawyer named keith davis
who
when we did our initial expose on
hustling in 1981
was the person who went around to the
courtrooms with us showed us what was
going on sort of
exposed a lot of the conduct that
ultimately became the central piece of
greylord the prosecutors by and large of
course we portray as very politically
ambitious people i think a lot of them
were
well motivated did a very good job
and
were certainly not anti-heroes but i
mean they were just doing their job
to me
keith davis would be the hero of
greylord and you and mr tui were working
where at the time
a chicago lawyer is a
it's a monthly publication that it's now
11 years old and we've done
investigations into
corruption in the judiciary and the
legal profession for
for these 10 years and that's where we
why we got onto this story so early on
and were able to find out so much about
it how long was it before
the city's major daily newspapers were
writing about it regularly
they didn't write about it regularly
until the u.s government began to leak
it
leaks from the prosecutor's office that
this investigation was going on and then
of course it was banner headlines
but that wasn't until 84 83 or 84. why
can you knowing how the system works how
the government sometimes tries to
influence the media the like why was the
justice department leaking the story at
that point what what did they see as a
as an end to be served
they wanted to
this is my view i mean they would they
would dispute this but i think that they
wanted to create a general feeling of
paranoia among the people who were under
investigation and get them to come
forward and and cooperate
furthermore the story had actually begun
to leak to some of the targets
they had served a subpoena
on one of the lawyers who had been
involved in payoffs to judges
he had been to a defense lawyer and so
they knew it was just a matter of time
until it was going to to leak
and they controlled it very well they
they leaked it to very specific people
and
resulted in massive
international publicity
months and months and months before the
first indictments came down
in the early days before the popular
press got involved in it was this ever a
dangerous story for you to write
oh i don't think so
no i
i don't think that
you know
most of the judges involved here
in this
corruption not all of them but most of
them were really
rather pathetic they had
bad alcohol habits they were alcoholics
what many of them were doing was just
taking enough money to support a good
drinking habit you know 50 100 a day to
pay the bar bill at night
and
no i don't think there was any danger
that
anybody was going to be killed or
anything like that and there were
certainly no threats that came to our
attention in the end out of both the
sting operation and the in the
larger investigation how many
indictments how many convictions there
were 86 or 87 indictments and uh virtual
they have all been convicted with two
exceptions
and among those are 14 judges and the
rest are court personnel and lawyers
when you look at the sentences
what was the attitude by the judicial
system in in policing its own
you got white sentences heavy sentences
oh i think they were extremely heavy i
think that the the sentences were were
very heavy in fact i think the federal
judiciary when it came to dealing with
this problem
was appalled
and many federal judges of course came
out of the state system
and
were they were
genuinely appalled by what they found
yet you indicate that that it continues
the corruption continues
there has unfortunately there's been no
systemic change in the system
it continues to operate pretty much like
it did in the past now this practice of
hustling i mean that's largely gone it
was too apparent and too open
but
whatever the underlying problems were
which i believe stem from the political
selection of judges
the lack of independence of the third
branch of government from the other two
branches
that
the possibility the political fix that
remains it's as prevalent today as it
ever was
we've driven some of the worst crooks i
think off the bench and
and people are a lot more subtle but
this is not the end of judicial
corruption in cook county what's it
going to take for a systemic change
well first i think we'd have to change
the system in which the chief judge is
chosen he's presently elected by the
other judges of the court the ones
he's supposed to be supervising now
that's not really much of a very good
management structure as i'm sure
absolutely every management consultant
in the world would agree
the other is that we need to change the
way in which judges are chosen
we need a it's called a merit selection
system we need to to replace this
political
selection process with a merit selection
system now those are the two biggest
steps that could be taken and of course
neither of those has been taken where do
you see an impetus for change like that
coming from
if this investigation and the massive
publicity
couldn't do it
i don't know what really could
in recent years however it's
been rather
interesting to observe that the
democratic organization has lost
control it's no longer
the monolithic force in chicago that it
once was
in 1984
the democratic
slated candidates for judge
were defeated
by people who happen to have irish names
this is a big irish
city and so if your name is kelly or
o'malley you have a very good shot in a
much better shot than someone with a
non-irish name with a
it just turned out that in 1984 the
organization or the machine slated
people with non-irish names they had
opponents who had
irish names or more irish sounding names
and they won
it's sort of uh
you know left me with the view that
the only
person who could favor the present
system is an anarchist because there are
the organization can't control it
anymore so ultimately when the
organization loses control
and the politicians understand
that they've lost control
perhaps we can have a meaningful reform
but this investigation didn't bring that
about
why did you and james tui decide to turn
this into a book
well we just thought it was
one heck of a story
it's got
the elements of
guys and dolls it's got tragic elements
comic elements
and it's an important story
that had never been told and there was
no other way
one of the reviews said that gee there's
very little new here there's no new
research most of this had been published
before
in various publications including our
own and that's true
but there was no place for
that it was all pulled together and
that's what we
thought we could do in this book is this
a peculiarly chicago story are there
lessons for the country to learn from
this
i would hope
that it's not as bad anywhere else in
the country as it was or is in chicago
but just like police corruption is not
a purely chicago phenomena that
exists everywhere
i assume that this exists
to some extent in every large
metropolitan area
talked a little bit about the
federal
judiciary being outraged by this
do you know for sure or have any sense
that it is
encouraging some review of the process
in other cities around the country
i really have no idea except of course
the reform
there
the bar the organized bar has become
increasingly concerned with ethics
appearances and i think it's probably
having an effect everywhere
but i don't really have any first-hand
knowledge of
what's going on anywhere except in
chicago if you and james tui could write
an epilogue to greylord a few years from
now what would you hope that would be
i would
i would hope that we could find more
heroes
i would hope that we could
that we could find someone
who would
be the hero of the sequel i'd
i'd like to find at least one
good honest person in the system
to make a hero and unfortunately we
didn't have that this time that will
have to wait for the sequel
and uh
in addition to that
ultimately that the system will be
reformed as well or have you given up
hope on that well i would hope
that the system
would be reformed and that that's why we
would have a hero
who finally brought this about
what did you learn by writing the book
anything
yes you always learn things when even if
you before you actually start writing
something it helps you know
clarify the thought process
that's why i see sometimes courts issue
decisions and say that a written opinion
will follow i think that that's wrong
because i think the writing process is
what clarifies
that opinion and the thought process and
you
in the writing process you run against
problems that hadn't occurred to you or
that you hadn't focused on quite as well
and you learn a great deal
and i think
that at one point
it just really dawned on me
how thoroughly
corrupt
this entire system
was i mean we had judges who were
popping off the bench to take payoffs in
the middle of trials
we had in one case a lawyer who was
literally involved and
if you invited him to dinner at your
house he'd case the joint for his
burglar friends he once set up a money
laundering scheme
for uh
some friends of his and he changed uh
some gold cougarands for cash for them
in his office and arranged to have them
hit in the unmugged in the lobby of his
building we had prosecutors who were
authorizing
the bugging of clients by lawyers i mean
to me this is just
just thoroughly a thoroughly distasteful
thing that was exposed here and
it really
having covered it for all these years
writing this book brought that all into
focus
for me
rob warden is co-author with james tui
of greylord justice chicago style thanks
for talking with us thank you
[Music]
this interview with author rob warden
will re-air at 12 25 a.m eastern time
which is 9 25 in the evening for our
viewers on the west coast
stay with us now for coverage of a panel
discussion on